you're on the live
stream good morning everybody the time
is 10:00 uh it's time for me to resume
this public inquiry as you all know my
name is Matthew nun I'm the inspector
that's been appointed by the Secretary
of State to conduct the inquiry and to
determine the appeal that is made by
Kates be strategic land limited relating
to a site um
in Burnham Road uh land off the Groves
in latchington just the usual reminders
um if people could put their phones on
silent mode please just to stop any
disturbances um and uh I haven't been
advised that there's any um fire alarm
today so I assume if the fire alarm goes
we need to evacuate the building and as
advised yesterday we I believe it's
through this door here um and uh we uh
exit and assemble outside just to remind
everyone again uh I'm sure you you're
aware we're we're being live streamed
for those who wish to watch uh
proceedings
online
um uh I have no further particular
points to raise apart from um I was I'll
I was going to ask uh if there had been
any progress from the council's side on
the condition schedule um Mr
Willcox so yes I my understanding is
it's been sent to your case officer pins
this morning I think we we're at a point
where they're entirely agreed apart from
two of them where there are minor
outstanding disputes for you to resolve
so fine but otherwise they're in they're
in good shape and we've got as far as
we're going to get okay um in terms of
um how we proceed this morning um we
we've effectively got two witnesses to
hear haven't we we've got Mr milc and Mr
Armstrong
um in terms of um time estimates um I
think Mr uh Mr K you you initially said
you'd be about 45 minutes in Chief with
with each I think that's about right sir
yes yeah and uh Mr W Cox do you know
roughly how long you might be in Cross
sir I I think I will be between 30 and
45 minutes with Mr mil
and I'd have thought
between 75 and 90 minutes with Mr
Armstrong I'm taking the view sir that
you you have the you have the council's
case from Mr comm's answers yesterday I
expect you have the appellant's case
from myed friend's questions yesterday
so rather than going over a lot of
territory that you'll already be
familiar with so I'm going to be be
quite focused well that's that's uh
helpful thank thank you very much Mr
Wilcox for that um that means we should
we should get through the evidence I
would hope reasonably speedily than uh
this morning um in terms of the overall
program of the
inquiry I I obviously need to undertake
a site visit
um my view is that it it may well be
possible for me to do that unaccompanied
uh I I obviously seek both your views on
that uh does anyone Mr kuk any views on
that no um I I've taken instructions we
we we discussed it last night Sir um we
don't see a need for you to be
accompanied um we we we'll discuss the
zone of visual influence in a little
while and you can see the viewpoints and
they set out quite clearly in the
appendices to Mr milc so no doesn't need
to be accompanied as far as we are
concerned you have permission to go on
site um I think it would be helpful
respectfully for you to go on site and
to look back at the settlement but I I
don't think it's necessary for you to
walk the
entirety of the site I think you'll get
a flavor from from the North and the
southern Fields um I think are are just
one sort of note of caution we're going
to look at the the viewpoints of photo
montages they are actually on a on a
road and we wouldn't encourage you to be
standing there with the photo montages
out no you you use those as a desk based
tool but if you were to drive because
that after all is the experience that
people have and that that's our only
note of caution but I'm not going to
tell you how to suck eggs and to take a
side visit so you'll be more than
capable of doing no no we we won't we
we're we're always instructed not to you
know take risks as it were um Mr Wilcox
so I I agree with Mr kak so it's it's
not the kind of site or the kind of
dispute where I think you're going to
need to be shown where to look at it
from or where there are going to be any
challenges around orientation so from
from our perspective so I'm very happy
for you to do it on acc company I mean
if there's if I you know if either side
wants to or if you want to agree a a
route or or um you know certain
viewpoints that you think I should um
view the site from if you know if you
want to work together on on a on a sort
of an approved route for me to to do
then I'm that would might be helpful
from from my perspective well perhaps so
once once Mr milr is done with his
evidence perhaps he and Mr Coleman can
have a discussion about that and up with
a plan for you yes I think that would be
helpful that would be helpful and given
the weather forecast which I gather is
not necessarily very good over the next
few days uh I mean it does make sense
for me to do it unaccompanied then then
it means I can do it at an appropriate
time when the weather conditions are uh
good as it were as it were rather than
arranging a visit and it's pouring with
rain or we've got gale force winds as we
seem to have had the last couple of days
um all right good um are there any other
procedural points anyone wants to raise
at this uh just one just one sir if I
may I think we'll probably come on to
the section 106 briefly tomorrow morning
um I just again don't need an answer now
but whe whether you think it might be
necessary for my instructing solicitor
to to turn up and attend as I as I said
in opening there's nothing controversial
between the two of us um no third
parties or local residents have raised
any issues it it I'll be honest with you
it's just a point of cost and
convenience that if you've no
particular points or or or or or issues
to understand then we probably wouldn't
have him here but of course he he can be
so sir if if if you could let us know by
the end of today yeah um that that would
be very helpful thank you no I I I'll
what I will do is I'll I'll have a
another look at the obligation and and I
mean if it's fairly straightforward it
may well be that you know um we don't
need solic a solicitor here from your
side I I wonder if is it possible for me
to have a paper version of the of the
latest draft that that would assist
me um if that could be provided I don't
know whether the council or I mean not
necessarily this minute but um um in due
course um that would be that would be
helpful do you want a hard copy of the
conditions as well uh indeed that would
also be helpful if they're if they're
ready for um for to be distributed that
we'll we'll get that done for I mean not
it doesn't have to be done this minute
but those are two things that would be
very helpful paper copy of conditions
and
obligation
um right and I I'll let I'll have a a as
I say I'll I'll have a look at the
obligation again uh Mr kuk and and it
may well be we don't need the solicitor
so but I'll let you know by close of
play today um thank you all right um
anything from your side just to mention
so you should I hope have had the sil
compliance statement by this point as
well right has that been emailed to the
I I believe it was emailed last night
yeah I only asked for it to be okay
there's sometimes a bit of a delay in
things finding their way to me um I'll
check that well perhaps so when we're
doing hard copies I I'll print you all
of those as well so you can you can have
it this way that's fine that's fine all
right good
unless there's any other procedural
points then we'll we'll we'll get on to
the evidence um and uh Mr mil um thank
you sir and and all you will need is uh
the proof and appendices of Mr mil Crist
and uh the statement of common ground
and I think core document 3.1 which is
the plan okay um so Mr milre let me
introduce you um your your name is
Charles milc is that correct that's
correct you're a director of EDP you
provide advice as a chartered landscape
architect and environmental planner is
that correct yes that's correct your
qualifications include a ba honors
degree in landscape architecture from
the University of gloustershire and a
postgraduate diploma in the same subject
you've been a fully charted member of
the landscape Institute since 2006 and
you're an associate member of The
Institute of Environmental Management
and assessment is that correct yes
that's correct uh you Poss more than 20
years experience in professional
practice first as a landscape consultant
for halcro and subsequently from 2005 to
2011 as a project landscape architect at
the Derek Lovejoy partnership in
Birmingham you joined EDP in March 2011
where your role progressed to discipline
lead for the landscape team and you were
appointed as our director in 2018 is
that correct yes that's correct um I
won't uh embarrass you by reading all of
your uh experience uh but You' tell us
at one point . 7 that the evidence you
prepared is true to the best of your
knowledge and belief is that correct yes
that's correct and we also just note at
1.8 uh of your evidence that you were
instructed in 2021 and since then you
have provided landscape advice to the
applicant from the outset of the design
process and you authored the landscape
and visual impact of praisal is that
correct yes that's correct thank you
well I'm going to take all of that as
read Mr milc if if I if I
may and ask you to start at
3.4 um and I'm not going to ask you to
to read this out and the inspectors
indicated that that he's read it and
understood it but if you could just turn
to your 3.4 and also uh turn to edp1
which is
the uh illustrative master plan and just
explain in your own words what you say
the important characteristics of the
site
are uh thank you uh
so site is um is is typical of the local
area it's a rectilinear um agricultural
field parcel or actually part of two
Fields um it sits at a low level
approximately 10 m above um aod uh and
directly adjacent to the Eastern side of
latchington Village
the fields are currently uh well
certainly when I've visited the site um
put over to arable cropping um and
they're
compartmentalized by hros along the
eastern boundary some of which are
fragmented um and do not extend the full
length of the Eastern site boundary um
in essence we are we would be making a
new site boundary in that
location um the to the east one of the
main influencing factors really of the
site in general um is the settlement
Edge to the west of the northern field
parcel we've got some there's an area of
residential housing on Laing road which
I believe is from around the
1960s uh and then further south adjacent
to the southern field parcel uh there's
a much more contemporary development um
of more modern housing which directly
abuts the field
parcel as I noted earlier the site is
very characteristic of The Wider denji
Peninsula um which
comprises as Mr Coleman discussed
yesterday large areas of agricultural
Farmland um with rectal linear roads and
rectal linear field
Parcels so in terms of the main
influences over the site as I mentioned
it's
the the the influence that the
neighboring residential areas provide
it's it's it's a settlement Edge in that
respect quite clearly um the rinear
nature of the site is also
characteristic and and quite prominent
um and due to the flat
topography there's a there's a
definitely a sense of of foreshortened
views in terms of The Wider visual uh
impact um and what I mean by that is
that the vertical elements within the
wider landscape have a more of an
influence than they might do in
restricting um visibility of of the site
and correspondingly the the settlement
from the East uh and on that point if
you just turn to
3.12 and you discuss that
the the theoretical zone of visual
influence a concept with which the
inspector will be very familiar can you
turn please to
cm5 so I have that on page 39 of your
appendices and could you just explain
what
the theoretical zone of influences of
the
site indeed so so what this plan shows
uh as a yellow wash uh is the area we
termed zone of primary visibility which
is the area within which the the
proposals would be most visible within
the surrounding landscape it's not the
only place they might be visible but is
the primary area where they um they
would be visible as you can see
certainly for a site of this scale it it
does
um present a very limited area um
predominantly within 1 kilometer um and
the reason for that is is almost
entirely due to the flat nature of the
site and the corresponding screening
that's provided by both the existing
settlement of lingon which screens views
from the West um and intervening
features such as um farmsteads trees
head RS Etc um which restricts visib
visibility to the east um to the
Northeast you can see view point 8 um
that sits on a on a slightly elevated
piece of topography near lauring Hall um
and that's one one of the relatively
rare elevated points in the in the
surrounding landscape from where you'll
be able to or where you can see lingon
in a slightly different
setting yeah and so it's probably not
for me to say but it might be that this
is a a good starter for the for the for
the site visit itinerary um but just
trying to understand this then because
previously your analysis mentioned about
the absence of public rights of way
across the site Etc so from
where if anywhere does one appreciate
the identity of the settlement of
latchingdon which of these
viewpoints so the pr the principal
viewpoints which which represent uh
transient views along the local road so
steeple Road and Burnham Road um
viewpoints 1 to 4 uh and viewpoints 6
and8 um primarily one to four and six
where you when you drive towards the
settlement um the settlement Edge comes
into view when you're relatively close
to it there are glimpses of it further a
field um and
that is really the limit of where you
experience the settlement in its
landscape context okay so it's as you
experience it on the roads approaching
and I think that explains why you've
taken the photo montages from those
locations is that right yeah in indeed
those are um the the few views where you
will experience that change in context
and we attempted with the photo I've
attempted with the photo montages to
illustrate uh the worst case uh change
and it's Al sorry it's also notable just
the limitation in public rights of way
um there's evidently a good network of
public rights of way to the west of the
Village um which go south from the
street up towards the higher ground um
but to the east of the settlement um
there's a real pocity of Rights of way
which is in my experience relatively
unusual for a for an area of rural uh
England
um the the next thing then is to look at
the development of the landscape
strategy could you turn to your page 14
and paragraph
4.8 and could you also then so 4.8 page
14 but also plan EDP 2 which is the
landscape strategy
plan soorry that's actually appendix
appendix EDB 2 yes correct
and again we've got this down in writing
and we've got it in front of us here and
it's annotated and respectfully I I
think we can all follow the plan but do
you want to just give us the the edited
highlights but concentrating please on
the
approaches um that we've looked at what
the design response has been to the
approaches from where you will
experience um the site so yeah so the
yeah the landscape strategy shown on uh
on my appendex cdp2 and that that was
conceived throughout the the design
evolution of the site um initially there
were two larger blocks of development
North and South um and in response to
Our advice that was limit that was the
Western buffer if we can call it the
Western Green buffer sorry the Eastern
Green buffer um has been enhanced
considerably since the initial uh
concept schemes uh were or concept um
plans were um developed
and that's really in response
to the existing settlement edge of
lingon which provides a
somewhat um fragmented disorganized um
character and that's largely due to the
the different ages of residential
dwellings along that along that boundary
um and there was a real opportunity here
to to use what is a considerable part of
the appeal site to provide an extensive
area of public open in space extensive
areas of planting which provide
obviously huge amounts of biodiversity
net gain um and in doing so allow views
from the East to
be I won't say entirely screened but the
the the views of the development beyond
that uh Eastern landscape buffer would
present a much softer uh integration
into the wider
landscape just in terms of numbers I
just do want to clarify that in my proof
there are two references to numbers of
trees one States approximately 474 trees
and the other one States 747 I just
wanted to confirm the number in the
conclusion which is 474 is the correct
number okay do you want to just strike
out the one that's incorrect where where
which page would that be
okay
sorry with me um so on page 23 of my
Proof Set
23 the first bullet under paragraph
6.6 and and the change we're making is
to
474 uh sorry so the the first bullet
under 6.6 should be 474 yes so not
instead of 747 yeah bit of
numerical yes
that's incorrectness there apologies for
that no that's absolutely fine and the
other references within the summary and
that's correct that is correct thank you
and uh if I then just think about that
that Viewpoint that we looked at from
steeple road then what what I see in the
the the North
Eastern uh portion um is an area of
Woodland so what effect will that have
on assimilating the development and
screening impacts from the approach
roaches along steeple road so so the
reason for the Woodland just in the
first instance was there were two two
primary reasons for that the first one
being as you point out the uh the
ability of that piece of wooden to
provide a soft integration and further
screening as you approach the settlement
from the East um and it's also
reflecting one of the key
characteristics within the Essex
landcape character assessment um which
is the small areas of
Woodland okay and then just just give me
an idea if I'm then looking at the the
the what you call the southern parcel
and I'm approaching then uh from the
east on Burnham raid and I'm looking
back across the site and if I look sort
of the area of the allotments what what
I see just above the allotments is and
obviously this is illustrative but I see
some perimeter planting a horseshoe of
planting some planting what looks then
to be an informal path and another row
of planting and then a a road and then I
see the first elev Elation of the houses
what's the distance from that sort of
the front elevation of that house to um
to to to the eastern boundary so the
front elevation of which house well just
I I'm I don't know if people can see I'm
sort of just trying to understand what
the the distance is from there to there
if people can see that yeah I mean on
using the scale bar it's
approximately that's approximately 60 M
M and so an area of 60 m in which one
could have structural Landscaping what
impact is that going to have on
assimilating and addressing views as one
approaches from Burnham road then to the
South it's it as really shown on the on
the photo montages which we'll obviously
take a look at look at a bit later on um
the first principles of landscape
strategy were to retain uh existing
vegetation so where where that was
available where that was possible um so
that includes the eastern boundary and
also the um the hro through the middle
of the two in between the North and
South um development
Parcels um the benefit we have with this
proposal and the space provided is that
we we are able to have a line of of
hedro with hedro trees along the eastern
boundary and then different layers of
vegetation between that hedro and then
the first houses uh and that would
include as I say the hedro planting
around the sustainable drainage um
basins and the the play area further
planting along the rights of way and
then an additional hrone planting um
along the the frontage of the
residential
units okay thank you and then we'll take
these matters briefly um 412
then what was the position of officers
uh and uh in particular the the case
officer about the nature of the design
and the landscape strategy at the point
of
determination the effectively the the
landscape strategy uh and and the
general landscape and visual impact were
were not really um in dispute within the
O in the uh committee report um and the
officer made some fairly detailed
analysis against the molden district
design guide um and ultimately
concluding that the the proposals
responded very positively to that um
both in terms of the amount of green
infrastructure and planting um but also
in terms of the um development density
and the the the requirement within the
design guide uh for having lesser dense
development on the Eastern Edge next
please uh your page 23
6.7 so page page 23 and we have table
EDP
6.1 and you set out the landscape
effects in summary on the site the
immediate surroundings and then the
coastal Farmland LCA do you see that I
do and if you then turn over the page to
six sorry not over the page but to page
27 and
the summary of the visual impacts are
that they would be localized and limited
do you see that I do uh and it says
there's sufficient layering of
vegetation within the surrounding flat
landscape to ensure the extensiveness of
visual change would be limited to a
limited number of local
receptors okay so that was the analysis
if you turn please to
2.2
so then at the point of
determination what if any criticism had
there been of that landscape and visual
assessment there had been absolutely no
no comment or criticism at that point we
um it was notable there was no response
uh from any landscape offices uh within
the council to the application um from a
landscape perspective um and ultimately
the the consider of the scheme within
the uh the report to committee at
4.6.1 uh was incredibly brief um and
really
summarized uh in a very similar fashion
the the extent of effects um that we
have and I did in the lbia what uh if
one looks just at 2.1 what reference is
there if any to character and appearance
or identity of latchingdon in the reason
for
refusal uh there is no reference to that
uh if you turn please to your
3.2 and
3.3 so page
eight I mean briefly you you're saying
there that it's the site's not
designated has no statutory status or
identified quality it's not valued um no
listed buildings in the site no
conservation areas or schedule monuments
you reference the pill box you refer to
ecological designations and the the TPO
I think in fact we see these marked uh
on plan
cm3 on page
37 but just just briefly how constrained
in landscape and visual terms is the
site really as set out at 3.2 um the
site is incredibly unconstrained in
landscape and visual terms um and in
fact in the environmental terms um and
and the conclusion I must draw from from
the lack of uh requirement um for the
council to seek um any further
professional advice or opinion at the to
inform the decision um leads me to
believe that they the same view has
taken in terms of the lack of Technical
and designatory constraint um obviously
that's not to say that the site doesn't
have any value all all Landscapes have
some value um but it provides a very
useful context to start understanding um
how high up the sort of value scale if
you like a site sits uh next please
could you pick up the statement of
common ground at 8.23 so CD
9.3 statement of Common Ground paragraph
8.23
and uh we note at 8.23 so in the light
of that the landscape impacts and those
visual impacts there's no objection
raised by the local Authority on
landscape grounds it's agreed that any
landscape effects are likely to be
limited and localized as set out in the
lvia is that correct it is yes um any
dispute that there can be high quality
design delivered at Reserve matters
stage uh
no um is there what's the agreed
position on impact on residential
amenity uh it's agreed that there's no
uh impact on residential immunity okay
so this leaves then the point raised in
Mr Coleman's evidence about policy s112
so could you just turn to that
please
so CD
3.1 uh page 18 of the
PDF policy
s112 and uh what that's telling us is to
maintain the rural character of The
District without compromising the
identity of its individual settlements
if I deal with the first part maintain
the rural character of The
District well to to what extent if at
all is that a landscape
point I think yeah it's exactly it is a
landscape point I I would consider rural
character to be uh the same really as
the impact upon landscape character on
published landscape character um and in
this respect there is clear agreement
that the impacts of this proposal are
limited and localized um I would
completely um maintain that the
character of The Wider District on the
basis of such localized landscape
impacts would be
maintained okay uh is there any
technical competing assessment from a
competent professional to your
analysis no no no there
isn't uh so if we then look at the the
next part with without compromising the
identity of its individual settlements
we've agreed with Mr Coleman that this
is not a no harm policy it's not a no
change
policy um it requires the exercise of a
professional judgment how do you say one
should exercise a professional judgment
to reach a conclusion on whether the
identity of latchington has been
unacceptably
compromised the way I've I look at this
is is very similar to how one assesses
impacts upon landscape character um in
that respect we most of the time have a
landscape character assessment to
provide us with an Evidence base which
provides a baseline of the landscape
character typically Pro provides a list
of key
characteristics um against which we
would then assess the proposals um and I
I consider it is very similar if not
exactly the same for
considering issues around identity one
needs to understand what the identity is
to then understand how and if the
proposals impact that
identity and so if you turn please to
your
6.30 of your
[Applause]
evidence
it's there that you address what is the
current identity of latchingdon and if
you turn to the top of page
29 um could you just briefly explain
then what what you say is the current
identity of latchington
so first in the first instance I've
looked at how the settlement sits within
its its wider context So within the
wider landscape and not
um not the detail of the internals of
the settlement which I can move on to um
from from the higher level uh and as Mr
Coleman touched on yesterday uh it's
it's a small to medium Village in a
wider agricultural landscape um and if
we can just make reference to my proof
plan
cm1 which is on page
[Applause]
sorry this Sor my proof plan cm1 no it's
at the back of my M text sorry for the
uh
SL see what page
355 thank you very
much so from that again it's the same
plan I think Mr Coleman Drew reference
to yesterday uh there are there are a
number of other settlements within the
wider landscape so mland um althorne
lingon um and even cold Norton which
have a broadly similar um character in
terms of being on the intersections of
Roads um and being in part defined by
the by the the sort of rectal linear
landscape character that exists in this
area um and what you can well I think
you can see from this plan is that
that lendon and indeed those other
settlements are not what I would
consider truly linear they're they're
broadly linear in in the sense that they
are uh located along roads or certainly
started as as settlements that um are
located along roads but then have grown
over the last 100 years or so um
into more of a mixture of of linear and
nucleated uh form um as the requirements
have have been for growth in those small
settlements
okay and uh if you just look at at the
next one cm2 on page
[Applause]
36 what what evidence do we see
currently
of cuxs in in and around the vicinity of
the
site so the it's clear the original
linear core of or linear hearts of the
settlement has um it Still Remains it's
it still remains in and around the the
church uh and the school um but I think
since about the 1960s there has been a
number of areas of growth you can see
just to the right of the number three on
that plan Laing Road um which is a more
nucleated extension out from Burnham
Road similar to um the North North at I
believe it is ransy close in Meadow Way
uh there's another uh close stroke cuac
there and then more recently there are
the developments to the to the
immediately to the east sorry
immediately to the west of the appeal
site and on the other side of Burnham
Road north of the bowl Center that's not
actually shown on this plan um but uh Mr
Coleman's plan in his proof which we
referred to yesterday today shows uh
that area now uh obviously partially
built out if not completely built out
the point being that that the settlement
has organically moved away from the
truly linear uh and now contains um
almost more characteristic nucleated
forms off that Central
Road um but but what is there if
anything of any intrinsic landscape or
townscape Merit in a linear as distinct
from a nucleated
settlement nothing specific they are
both types of settlement form both have
their qualities um and clearly as
lington has grown both have their
qualities within lington as well and so
if you then look at your next Point your
please sorry just before I go there what
then if anything is the relevance of
scale to the existing
identity in the same way as building
style presence of Green Space um scale
is one part of the The Wider makeup of
the identity uh of anywhere of a
settlement or a town um indeed I think
with when you have settlements of of of
the type of latchingdon where where
where they historically
run along a road you actually get a a
sense of a slightly larger scale because
you you experience
the the settlement for slightly longer
than you would if it was a truly
nucleated
settlement and so an
arithmetical comparison of numbers of
households at different points in time
and or a comparison in two dimensions of
site coverage how useful do you say say
that is as an exercise in trying to
understand the existing identity of a
settlement and or what the impact the
identity will
be it's not particularly helpful in
defining character and identity um in
the same way I draw a comparison to to
landscape character effects um although
site size and scale is a relevant factor
it's more about the threshold of the
receptor to to receive the change that
is
proposed so next please if you then turn
to your
632 could you just briefly explain what
you say then the impact is on the
identity of
Ling so from a wider sense um there will
be a change to the Eastern edge of the
settlement as it's experienced from
areas to the east particularly from the
from steeple Road um and Burnham Road um
there will be a new settlement Edge uh
quite clearly
um in my professional opinion the the
proposed settlement Ed that could be
created courtesy of the significant
Western landscape buffer that's proposed
would actually improve that relationship
with its agricultural hint land it
certainly wouldn't fundamentally change
that relationship there would still be
AG cultural land on the edge of
latchington Village um in terms of the
the value to those uh features of the
settlement more internally so the the
historic core uh the listed buildings I
think it's an agreed matter that there
is no unacceptable impacts to um the
church or or other listed buildings and
similarly it was Mr Coleman mentioned
yesterday the views uh of the church
from The Wider landscape um those views
were would by and large remain uh intact
there would still be views of the church
as you drive and walk around uh the
local area particularly to uh the East
where we would be having an impact so
finally then let's just look at the
photo montages because I want to try and
understand as it were from where one
might experience any change to the
identity of the settlement and I think
we'll start then please in the the
landscape
appendices with EDP 8 which I have at
page 14 at the top right hand
[Applause]
corner do you have a page number yes
page 14 sir 14 of the hard copy yeah
it's it'll be a different page of the
electronic
copy so it's photo viewpoint
ed8
and so so you you you you'll recall if
you if you want to have this to hand
with uh was it
cm4 or cm5 rather then you can see where
these viewpoints
are we're to the Northwest at just near
Laing Hall on a public right of
way
um how if at
all sorry we obviously see latchington
here what experience does one have of
latchingdon
so so just to put this view into context
this is one of the um relatively few
areas of elevated ground within the
within the local area from where views
of lendon are available um you can
clearly see lendon in the I'd say in the
middle distance um you can see the
Eastern edge of the settlement and then
looking further right to towards the I
presume is a horse shed you can see the
uh the church as a as a as a feature um
identifying the the core of the village
in essence what what you see although it
is partially screened by hedra in the in
the foreground um is the presence of a
village within a wider agricultural uh
landscape and this is this is a public
footpath isn't it yes yes so this is
this is um The View you would get from
uh the public right of way indeed yes a
view point8 on my yeah and and in terms
of the visible part of
the settlement that that I can see what
what part of it is it that I can see
it's fairly in the distant but you can
see the Eastern um edge of the village
uh you can see the uh the new houses
adjacent to uh the appeal sites um
Southern field field parcel uh and then
extending to the right towards the
church um slightly less visible as the
remaining um edge of the village so so
what I can see effectively is the rear
of the what you're saying a 1960s
housing off La Ling and then the more
modern
housing uh adjacent to the southern
parel yeah and actually there which
you'll see on site uh when you under
take your site visit so the the the new
the more contempor housing adjacent to
the appeal site Southern parcel um
provides quite a stark relationship to
the appeal site in the sense there's
very little um landscape buffering
between those houses and the site as
experience from this one of the few
available viewpoints will there be any
change to your experience to the
identity of settlement or any
unacceptable harm to the identity of
Ling in my view I just can't see how the
extension of the Eastern settlement edge
around about 120 meters to the
east with the proposed landscape
mitigation which would provide a much
softer um integration with
its transition into the agricultural
landscape the the overall identity of
lendon just in my view wouldn't change
it would still represent a settlement
within a wider agricultural landscape
and in some in for some views particular
this view I believe in the longer term
it would be even less visible um than it
is
now uh next please if you could turn to
again in the in the landscape
appendices page 30 viewp point 4 so this
is on the approach from steeple
Road this is the existing view sorry Mr
can yeah page 30 sir on the
yes Viewpoint for existing Baseline
view yes
correct and again so we can note the
presence of the steeple and what do you
want to say then again as to what what
is it that we looking at which is giving
some impression as to the identity of
the settlement as experienced from this
Viewpoint what we're seeing immediately
in the foreground is a is is the
characteristic agricultural arable
landscape um beyond that you have um a
varied settlement Edge to lingon uh to
the to the left hand side of that
settlement Edge you can see the more
contemporary housing um adjacent to the
appeal site Southern field parcel and
then extending to the right
you have the uh Eastern settlement
boundary extending all the way up to the
church um which again marks the core um
of the village and just so that the
inspector can can understand this is
what you are describing as the
relatively raw settlement Edge where
we're looking at the sides and Rears of
essentially modern Suburban housing is
that right yes that's that's correct
okay um then o over the page and we
understand that
this isn't a vvi this is just a a
blocking sort of uh tool but we see the
proposal raw and
unfiltered and then if one turns over
the page again to see the
effect with the structured
Landscaping so comparing this with the
year at 15 let's just understand some of
the assumptions that you've made this is
a winter view is that correct cor yeah
this is correct that's correct it was
taken in December uh
2023 um Mr Fitzgerald I think it was
yesterday who was concerned about the
characteristic view back to the church
and the Spire will there be any impact
to that view back to the church or the
Spire no no no the the the the part of
the site um you're welcome to look at
these if you're struggling to
follow no okay uh so yes the view of the
church uh spy remains um identifying the
core of Village of the
okay because because as a matter of
unanswerable fact the housing is not in
between the viewer and the Spire no it's
not and then in terms of assumptions
that you've made about Landscaping what
height would the trees be put in at the
trees would be put in at Heights of up
to 4.5 mters there would obviously
typically be a variety of heights um but
we would from a landscape design
perspective look to put the larger stock
uh in the areas where
you can get slightly more immediate
impact uh and then they are shown at
year 15 at between 10 and 15 meters um
using a
relatively
um unoptimised growth rate of 200 to 250
millimeters per year which is which is
very standard in terms of providing
images such as this so conservative a
conservative assumption I think is what
you're saying indeed and the eaves
Heights are assumed to be what the eaves
of the larger property so so the the two
story properties would be 6 M um and the
Bungalows would be 3 m so so what this
is showing then
is trees at approximately 10 m 10 to 15
M we've then got 50 or 60 M before the
housing at an Eaves height of 6 M and so
the overall effect of that substantial
area CU here we're looking through the
Woodland planting and then the
structured planting further along what's
the overall impact relative to what
we're looking at at the
moment in my view it's an improvement in
the sense there's a much softer
integration between the settlement and
The Wider landscape and and actually a
much more uniform
um spread across the view in terms of
how the settlement is perceived any
impact or any unacceptable impact on the
identity of latchingdon again in my view
in so as it contributes to the identity
the identity is relatively unchanged and
in some ways it's improved um how if at
all can one understand the
linearity if indeed it is linear anymore
the linearity of latchington do you
appreciate that it's linear in this
Viewpoint uh no and the extent to which
you would appreciate it is linear would
be exactly the same in the before and
after view uh and then if one looks at
um Viewpoint six then on the approach
from from Burnham
Road and we're just going to go briefly
through a similar exercise I'm again
want
to tell the inspector how to suck eggs
but what we see then from the south
we've got the existing Baseline view we
see the raw settlement edge of the
modern housing is that correct yes you
can see beyond uh the property known I
think as the Groves you can see the new
housing beyond that
um and this is just one one part of a
transient view this is you know as you
go further down um Burnham Road you'll
actually see more of the Contemporary
housing and less of the the other
housing uh to the north um but you can
see it spreads across most of the view
um with the church visible um by the
large evergreen tree in the middle of
the view over the page we see the
blocking
exercise without
planting and and then if one looks at
the position at year
15 what if anything do you say about the
impact on the
identity of latchingdon from this
Viewpoint in terms of the overall
identity of a settlement as perceived
from the wild landscape of a settlement
within an agricultural landscape that
hasn't changed
evidently the settlement has moved
closer to the viewer at this point um
but the overall character if you like in
terms of a settlement fronting onto
agricultural landscape uh remains um and
there'll be again as for the other
Viewpoint some more uniform character
across the view uh due to the the the
the potential um provided by that
Western buffer uh which provides that
potential to to plant um Native species
in in a very consistent and um planned
Manner and if one is concerned with how
the identity of latchingdon is
experienced on its approaches from the
East which is more successful in having
a transition from built form to open
Countryside the existing raw unfiltered
modern housing or what is
proposed in my view as landscape
architect is definitely the proposals in
place because you have that soft
integration which you just don't
currently have thank you sir those are
my
questions thank
you thank you Mr canuk just on on the
just a quick uh query from my part um in
terms of the the landscape buffer um you
you mentioned just now that it it will
be proposed to have sort of native type
species what sort of planting I'm I'm
sure it's set out in the in the
landscape strategy
but what what kind of Cl were you
proposing there the so if we just refer
to the appendix cdp2
um I've got the uh the yeah the
landscape strategy plan um ultimately so
that is for for detail determination at
the reserve matters stage but um
inevitably we would be typically
requested to um provide native hedro
planting native tree planting um so
Maples the typical ative British trees
some of which grow um faster than others
um which we tried to accommodate in
terms of the the mitigation appearance
in the photo montages um typically the
HED RS nearer the housing would be
better controlled or clipped down to to
be more easily managed whereas the
eastern boundary hedro could could be
allowed to grow out to provide um a
greater level of screening if that was
so um
desired it might be that
the level of of planting is something to
be um discussed and negotiated at
reverse Reserve matter stage if for
example a greater view of built
development was required um it's this
the exercise of producing both um the
landscape plan but more importantly the
the montages was to demonstrate or to to
reinforce my views of the effectiveness
of that
mitigation thank you I mean this may not
be a question for you actually uh Mr
milc it may be one for the planning
witness um Mr Armstrong but as things
currently stand as I understand it this
is an outline
application with the only matter that is
being approved at this stage is is um uh
access means of access um and as I think
Mr kak you made clear in your opening or
earlier yesterday we're not concerned
with the internal Road laout correct um
I'm just wondering you you've obviously
emphasized the importance of the sort of
softening Edge as it were proposed by
this
layout I'm just wondering how it's
proposed that that would actually be
secured in any planning permission I
haven't seen the latest version of the
condition so I don't know if if there's
one of the conditions says something to
the effect of uh you know development
shall be with in General accordance with
plan Ed whatever uh or I don't know if
that's the
way it may be Mr Armstrong is better
place iect Mr Armstrong is better place
but I would say it could not yes it can
be controlled through I'm sure the
distance and the extent of that um that
landscape buffer could be controlled in
some manner at the next it seems to me
that you know obviously I've heard your
your your examination in Chief and and
you you you you make um a lot of uh you
place great emphasis on the fact that
that there would be this this buffer
essentially on the Eastern side that
would would create a much softer Edge um
and I'm just uh wondering I mean it's
maybe something for Mr Armstrong and
uh to to to answer the question whether
you know the condition would be worded
in such a way to ensure that the layout
in the event if we did proceed with the
development that that could be you know
shrined in any proposal because it seems
to me if it doesn't have any kind of if
there's no mechanism for doing that you
know you could end up with houses right
up to the edge of the field um which
would be quite I mean even looking at
the um the
illustrative photo montages you know
year one they look pretty intrusive you
know I understand that over a period of
time
they'll it would be
shielded if if it were to go ahead head
but something maybe for for Mr Armstrong
i i i something we can certainly
consider and Mr Armstrong can perhaps
confirm later on I I just I I understand
what the point you're making on the like
the year one um uh photo montage I I
would just uh confirm that as Mr KCK did
that they are effectively block and they
don't they don't provide any finishes in
terms of materiality and that kind of
thing which would obviously soften um
soften their their views they wouldn't
be um constructed exactly as show
obviously I'm sure you appreciate that
it was I appreciate that that I mean it
is an outline application so all all
matters apart from from access are are
reserved matters effectively so that
would be for the council to um deal with
in due
course as I say if I were minded to
allow the appeal um but yeah no I was I
was more concerned about the the overall
layout really and and how that would be
secured you know to ensure this this
buffer yeah um did you want to come in
Mr I was just going to it may assist sir
one of the uh it's condition three I
think in the draft which has made its
way to you uh requires Landscaping
details including soft Landscaping to be
agreed and writing with the LPA at
Reserve matter stage so there is
something in the conditions that deals
with it whether it deals with it to the
extent that you're interested in is
perhaps a discussion best had at the
round table yeah I mean I just wonder
whether it's something that could be
potentially I appreciate Mr K you might
need to take instructions on this anyway
so uh but it I'm I'm just wondering you
know it would at least establish a kind
of broad framework as to to how the
development might proceed rather than
just leaving it completely open to you
know any F future developer to
build in a in a in a way that doesn't
ensure that buffer in a similar way to
eia you'd have a parameter plan which
would control this kind of I mean
parameter yes I mean that's right I
don't again I haven't I have got the
conditions now they've been sent to me
but I haven't had a chance to to look at
them um I don't know is there Mr Wilcox
is there anything about a parameter plan
for example in the first condition I'm
just having
now so I I don't think there is I I I
think
this is probably something that we we we
need to discuss all in in the condition
session but it does seem to me that it
might something that needs to be given
some thought to as to whether there
there could be some way of
um tying the development down slightly
more um in in accordance with the
illustrative master plan and and the
landscape strategy indeed I mean this
isn't an unusual approach i' I've had it
many times where where it's been agreed
that that can can occur um otherwise you
know what everything you've said this
morning is you know to some extent it's
neither here nor there if if if the
condition if if there's no condition to
secure that I understand that sir okay
thank you very much um so that we've
heard your uh in Chief um I was I
wondering whether it might be a good
time just to have a short break um I'm
very happy to do so sir I'm regretting
that huge
te
it does look pretty big uh indeed let's
let's have a um we we'll have a a 20
minute break so we'll come back at 20
11 um and uh we'll resume the cross
examination thank you very much
um
you are now live
again well good morning everybody we'll
resume the public inquiry um we're at
the point now where uh Mr Wilcox will
cross-examine uh Mr milcrest um so I'll
let you proceed Mr
Wilcox sir thank you very much Mr milre
good morning to you morning uh as you're
aware there's no landscape and visual
objection as such from the council so I
won't be asking you any detailed
questions about the lmv component as it
were we we won't need to trouble our
gvia 3es I'm sure we'll all be pleased
to hear but what I'd like to begin with
is is the nature of the issue between
the parties in particular in respect to
policy S1 so if we can just take up
please cor document 3.1 page
15 and we're just going to remind
ourselves of what key principle 12 has
to say and we see that it's concerned
with broadly two things it's concerned
with maintenance of Royal character and
it's concerned with compromising or not
compromising one should say the identity
of the individual set ments yes indeed
now you indicated in Chief Mr milc your
view that rural character here is
essentially analogous with landscape
character is that is that fair in
essence yes it can the rural character I
say to Countryside character landscape
character it's it's broadly the same
issue so you you've approached this
policy on the basis there synonymous
effectively agreed yes right one of the
difficulties with that Mr milr is that
we know that when the local plan means
landscape it says landscape doesn't
it uh yes S8 for instance refers
specifically to landscape issues when
landscape issues are
live aware of that yes indeed yes I
you're aware that the development plan
had a landscape and visual impact
assessment prepared in association with
it uh I believe so I was 100% aware of
that but yes well I I I promise you and
a number of a number ofas within the
plan where landscape and visual issues
are going to be Central to the
application of the policy it's
identified as one of the key evidence
documents you aware of that
yes if we go down to the bottom of page
16 paragraph
2.10 of CD 3.1 we see the key
evidence-based documents for S1 and what
we don't see here is the lvia do we uh
no we don't we can go please to page 45
within the same document
we find policy
S8
sorry and once again if we just go a
couple of pages down 2.14 key
evidence-based
documents once again we don't see the
lvia there do we no so in so far as
rural character is a matter for
consideration the authors of this plan
did regard that as sufficiently
landscape linked to make the lvia a key
document uh it's it's not referenced
under those two policies no now I
appreciate that what policy means of
course is a matter of interpretation and
that's a question for submission rather
than
for evidence but nevertheless I'll give
you a chance to comment on on some
matters rural character as a
concept is going to include things like
the characteristics of rural settlements
as they've evolved historically isn't
it in so far as they are part of the
wider landscape yes I would agree in the
same way um as landscape character
assessments often consider settlements
as well they're all part of the the
whole wider landscape but of course they
can be part of the rural character shape
of settlements linear settlements for
instance can be part of the rural
character of an area through his
hisorical Evolution without being part
of the landscape character can't they
rural character is a broader concept the
landscape character
here
um I'm not sure I would completely agree
that the two can be disassociated in
that same way landscape character looks
at all different scales National um
level county level District level um
and therefore encompasses historic
factors they often reference settlements
and historic settlement patterns um so I
don't I don't think there's something
that would be considered under rural
character that's not considered as part
of a wider landscape character
assessment
process similar point please is in
respect of settlement
size the size of a settlement is
something that can be relevant to Royal
character again without giving rise to
any adverse L and V impacts can't
it again this the size and scale of
settlements within their wider landscape
context is a relevant consideration for
character
yes moving on to the second of the S1
key Concepts please which is the
identity of individual
settlements again I don't for a moment
suggest that landscape and visual issues
are irrelevant to settlement identity
but they're not the only relevant
considerations are they the identity of
a s
can be heavily informed by things like
its size and shape yes yeah as I
mentioned in Chief the size and shape is
one component part in the same way as
building styles are and the surrounding
landscape are all contribute towards um
identity of the settlement they they all
contribute towards identity that's
that's helpful thank
you
uh factors such as size and shape uh and
their impact per se as it were their
their impact
as such without giving rise to landscape
and visual issues means doesn't it that
a change to size or shape might be
relevant to settlement identity without
manifesting as a component in an lvia
that's right isn't
it because the lvia is asking answering
a different question to settlement
identity uh yes LV is looking at
different aspects effect um
and I think as I've mentioned size shape
and scale how however it's however it's
um termed is a contributing factor to to
landscapes in the same way as it's a
contributing factor to
settlements and because they are
conceptually different is that the
reason that the lva doesn't mention
s112 um because I I checked it very
carefully this morning and 's no mention
of key principle 12 the as a as a policy
Informer that's identified specifically
within your
lva um I'm going
to take it as as as fact that it's not
referenced in there um we we tend to in
terms of lvia um obviously they're wide
reing um wide uh ranging documents and
tend not to focus entirely on it's a
part of the the consideration the policy
aspects but
equally landscape character assessments
published landscape character
assessments are uh another part of
that uh something else which isn't
mentioned in your lva or indeed in your
proof of evidence is the uh
characterization assessment that we
looked at with Mr Coleman now that's
that's right first of all as a matter of
fact isn't it uh it isn't yes it's not
referenced within those documents though
no and it is a material consideration
for the inspector isn't it because it
informs provides probably the most
detailed historical descriptions we have
about the rural settlement characters
and the identities of the rural
settlements that's before this inquiry
uh it it is something which assists in
that in that yes and in as far as it
assisting it it's not something you've
considered in your written evidence or
your lva it's it's not referenced in
there but I was obviously aware of the
document um and I I noce it's not it's
an evidence-based document so it was
reviewed um but it's not mentioned
specifically spefically for example
under policy S1 as a as a as a key um
evidencebased document so you were aware
of it but you chose not to mention
it it it was it was reviewed but it
wasn't mentioned specifically in the in
the lva there's other lots of other
documents that we will have reviewed and
read uh not necessarily mentioned
specifically in the
LV thank you if the inspector takes the
view as I'm going to invite him to in
closing that the the concepts of rural
character and settlement identity are
broader than the concepts of landscape
and visual impact I appreciate you said
what you've said on that if the
inspector prefers my reading of the
policy that they are broader
Concepts then it would follow doesn't it
that the absence of something like a
formal landscape designation for the
site is a matter of limited relevance
because landscape designations are
concerned with landscape impacts we're
concerned with a different question of
settlement identity so can I just go
back to First first part of your
question
regarding suggesting a difference
between the concept of rural character
and landscape and visual impact
assessment so do you mean a difference
in between rural character and Landscape
character I just wanted to clarify or or
because obviously lvia is a process
whereas Royal character you're
absolutely right that that's a very fair
point yes Royal character I'm going to
say is differ to lscape character in
this context Fair Point
um again I would
consider a landscape character
assessment considers the rural character
as a part of its um Baseline evidence
Gathering um it's a it's a
somewhat it's a different term in many
ways as I understand as I take it for
for broadly the same thing as I said
earlier rural character can be
considered on smaller scale in the same
way as landscape character can um and
could be considered on a larger scale as
well yeah and I I one has to draw a yeah
I I except you you say they're the same
uh if the inspector thinks they're not
the same yeah and that Royal character
means something different to landscape
character then it will follow wouldn't
it that the absence of landscape
designations for instance is going to be
of limited relevance because they're
they're aimed at different
targets okay I see what you're saying
I landscape designations and equally
ecological designations Heritage
designations they all contribute to um
the character of an area whether that be
a very small area or a much larger
area to me it's the same as how much
they would contribute to um the rural
character for example if one was to take
them as different um different things as
you as I think you're suggesting uh I
would still consider a landscape
designation would contribute to someone
considering the rural character because
landscape designations consider what one
might call Rural features so I I I I I I
I understand where you're coming from
that they could be considered different
but I I still think a landscape
designation would be equally relevant to
considering landscape character or rural
character in my own view now I I I
accept it's relevant it's going to be
less relevant if the concepts are
different though isn't it because if
landscape character means rural
character if if the concepts are
different there might be a difference in
how much the designation contributes to
do that yes that that's precisely my but
yeah as I say I I would consider that
they
contribute equally to those two things
if they were
different thank you if we can just have
a brief look please at policy
S8 page
45 it's just one all right I I
appreciate you're not the the witness to
address policy questions too I just want
to note
a brief point with you here and that is
that we we've got the the opening couple
of lines we've then got the
classification of the settlement types
and then we have the text the
countryside will be protected for its
landscape you see that I do yes and of
course what what we see here is that
landscape is protected natural resources
and ecological value as well as
intrinsic character and Beauty do you
see that I do so intrinsic character and
beauty under this policy is something to
be considered and protected
independently of landscape impact is
it because if if if it was folded into
landscape there'd be no need to have
said as well as I yeah I can see um I
can see that they are separate I'm to me
I I find that quite an unusual
distinction between the two and I would
I would take from that that landscape
probably means more towards landscape
fabric rather than character but but
obviously I can't be sure on on how
that's being interpreted in this point
um because ultimately land ape is
landscape character to me that's the
same as intrinsic character and Beauty
they're all're they're wrapped into the
same thing
ultimately thank you very much I'd like
to move on to some of the
characteristics of latchingdon uh both
on its own terms and as a a settlement
within the wider denji Peninsula
typology if I can put it that way and
for this please we're going to need the
mild and characterization assessment
which is called document
3.20
please let me let me know when you're
there yes I'm there you have it great
not at all now uh you you I think were
here yesterday Mr mil I think you you
saw the reference to latching them being
an agricultural settlement I one of the
Agricultural settlements yeah covered by
this document well in that case we we
don't need to trouble ourselves with
paragraph 3.4 we could agree that it's
it is an agricultural settlement for
these purposes if we can start please on
page uh PDF
55 which is where we get into the uh the
key characteristics of the Agri ultural
settlements on the denji yeah 6.0 yeah
6.0 that's it agricultural settlements
key
characteristics and
6.1.1 Begins by noting a number of
characteristics which I think are all
consistent with what you said in Chief
Mr milest happily that the villages are
in areas of early open field enclosure
often have nucleated or linear forms
that were well established by the late
medieval period you see that I do now as
uh point the was made made to uh made to
Mr Coleman yesterday as well a village
is either linear or it's nucleated but
the point here is that they are
established by the late medieval period
That's the uh yes yes that's that's the
the focus 6.1.1 yes not some of them
have moved from the original site but in
the majority of villages the Parish
Church still the dominant architectural
statement at the heart of the village
agreed yes if we can go on to the next
page please I'm sorry further down on
the page 6.14
or we get
into some description of the village
core and one of the features identified
about Village core within this is that
it tends to be clustered around the
roads most houses close to the road on
the fourth line you see that yes I do
see that and that affectively is
describing linear settlement typology
yeah linear or Ribbon yeah yes indeed
all ribbon yeah I think we can hopefully
agree those changes yeah the terms are
interchangeable for these purposes thank
you and then on the next page
6.1.5 tells us a little bit about what's
happened more recently from the early
1900s onwards so effectively in the last
100 years and again what's said here is
consistent with what you said in Chief
which is that we see the addition of
things like cu the sacks of housing
which form
equivalence of suburbs around those
linear cores do do you see all of that
yes I
do excuse
me so what we have being described here
uh linear ribbon Village core clustered
along the road with a church at its
Center and with later culdesac Dev
elements spreading around it from the
1900s onwards is very much latchingdon
isn't it yes that's that's an accurate
description i' would say yes it's an
accurate description of L chingen if we
can go on please to page
65 sorry 65 of the PDF of PDF 65 yeah is
is anyone using the hard copy or we just
electronic copy great if everyone's
electronic I can safely use the
electronic numbers I think mine's not
got number just can you just provide me
with a section yeah 6.3 specific
policies it's
headed okay yes I found do you have it I
do and as as with documents of this type
these these aren't development plan
policies no one's suggesting that what
these are is effectively expressions of
how to protect the key characteristics
that have been identified earlier is
that fair uh yes in in terms of what's
yes in terms of the context of this
document yes in terms of the context of
this document absolutely and the very
first of those expressions we see is
policy 6.1 and that identifies that the
predominant linear form of the
settlement should be maintained and
closes and CU theack should be avoided
do you see that I do this is in a
context of a document which has already
identified the delivery of closis and C
the sacks in the last 100 years which
may have weakened linear form and yet
nevertheless predominant linear form is
to be maintained do you see I do it's
also notable isn't it that of the linear
and nucleated settlement types which we
saw at
6.1.1 it's the linear forms not the
nucleated ones that are identified here
for
maintenance yes believe that's what he
said and the inference we can draw from
that is that the authors of this
document regarded the linear settlement
form as more important to the
agricultural rural character of the area
than the nucleated ones or it would be
the other way around uh I don't remember
it's stating that
specifically no as I said it's an
inference isn't it the inference we draw
if they thought the nucleated forms were
the important ones policy 6 want to
predict protect predominant nucleated
settlements but it doesn't it protects
linear ones but I think as as as we've
seen going through this this document
and and and my evidence in Chief
um my I take the view that we've kind of
organically moved away from the purely
linear admittedly broadly linear but we
are still having those linear forms as
described in here already contain
nucleated form within them and the
document recognizes that doesn't it
that's what we saw in ER 6.1.4 a little
earlier 6.1.5 forgive me when it talks
about the addition of cue saacs in the
last 100 years yeah yes it acknowledges
that those are part of um
the settlement they're part of the
settlement they're inevitably going to
turn a strictly linear form into a
broadly linear one if they move away
from the road I would agree yes and yet
in that context the predominant linear
form is nevertheless to be
maintained uh yes that's effectively
what this policy would be requesting yes
so this policy is requesting yes so when
we are considering whether or not a
further departure from the linear form
is acceptable or not we are to bear in
mind that this document proceeds on the
basis that it isn't
acceptable the linear form is to be
maintained not withstanding it may have
been weakened in the last 100 years but
assuming that nucleated forms currently
form part of the broadly linear form I
wouldn't say it's excluding further
nucleated form because that could
equally contribute to the broadly linear
form if it's if it's done so in the past
I've no reason to see why it wouldn't be
able to do so in the
future except of course that they want
us to avoid things like closes and culde
saacs don't they that's what S 61 tells
us it does say that but that in itself
is slightly inconsistent with the with
the characterization within this
document which which already concedes
that cux and closes form part of the
settlements that they are talking about
so perhaps we can summarize then that
being so the effect of 61 as being Theus
far and no
further
um I'm not sure I would read it like
that otherwise I I would presume it
would say
um something along those lines
specifically well it's not it's not
going to talk about demolishing existing
cult saxs is it that's not going to be
something it
says no it wouldn't say that but but I I
stand by the point that that if closes
and colder acts can be acceptable in the
current form why could they not be um
consider acceptable in the right place
precisely because they forward precisely
because they continue to weaken linear
forms which are already weakening and
further weakening would be unacceptable
because of its impact on agricultural
settlement
character I disagree with the sentiment
but I understand what you're
saying thank you very much with all of
that in mind can we take up please Mr
Coleman's proof simply because he's got
some plans side by side and it'll save
us jumping
around we're going to need Pages 18 and
19 please so when we get
[Applause]
there
are you there sir yeah yes great is
there there Mr mil Christ yes sir I'm
there than you great I'd like to begin
please with the uh figure 4.22 three
which is the bottom of page 19 areal
view of contemporary latchingdon that is
is what's there now in effect and this
is what you've described as broadly
linear uh yes indeed yes yes and one can
readily see why AR they the the
settlement although it's stretched a
little bit away from the roads it is as
you say broadly a linear structure
following the the road patterns in the
area uh yeah it's broadly linear with
with nucleated
forms um adjacent to what would be the
historic more historic and more linear
um settlement it's not specifically
shown on this plan but uh knowing the
village that that yes that the core is
effectively the original linear the core
is the yeah yeah quite quite so and what
we
note don't we from 4.2
2.3 is that there's been as as one might
put it a nucleated
expansion to the north of the settlement
up above where we see the red line Pub
had development pulled out away from the
road there yes we've had development
pulled out to the west of burnam road as
it travels North through the settlement
yes but to the east of Burnham Road as
the linearity is much more legible isn't
it
um I would consider those areas broadly
nucleated um in the sense that they have
divorced away from the the Central Road
uh and just just reflect on a previous
comment um obviously the
characterization document was produced
in
2006 um and if as as put to me it would
preclude further closes and colder
saxs clearly there have been closes and
CX as we see on this plan which is why I
bring it up now
um which have been agreed to be
acceptable since the
2006 characterization document so so I
suppose the question put to me was it
stops any well it's advising no more
closes and cue saacs actually there has
been quite a few at least three areas of
of closes and CX which have been um
built since that point well we need to
be a little bit careful there Mr milre
because at the time that those were
built as we heard from Mr Coleman
yesterday the Tilted balance was engaged
now I appreciate that isn't your
evidence but one of the effects of the
Tilted balance is that it can cause
development to receive permission not
withstanding the sort of conflicts that
things like s112 are designed to prevent
I appreciate that's not your evidence
I'm not going to push you on it but I do
note that so that we're all aware of the
direction of travel okay yeah I'm
unaware whether they were all approved
under that stes but it's probably
something for anything that was approved
at a time when the Tilted balance was
engaged might have been approved
notwithstanding this kind of adverse
impact um that would depend on the level
of harm obviously as to whether the
level of harm was considered to be um
overriding in the balance but I I take
your point thank you I won't I won't
push you on that any further you're not
you're not the planning witness uh so
that 4.22.18
we we can fairly easily understand how
that's going to be located if we were to
superimpose it on to 4. 22.3 we can see
where the roads curve and where the
field boundaries are agreed and what is
going to be apparent from that mental
superimposition as it were comparing the
two plans is that the proposal is going
to make the Eastern extent of the
settlement considerably more nucleated
than it is at present isn't
it um I would I would disagree with that
on the basis that we are delivering a
very wide or proposing to deliver a very
wide landscape buffer which which
wouldn't contribute if you like to the
to the figure ground in terms of built
form and open space um there would be an
addition to the nuclear to form on that
edge I would agree I wouldn't call it a
significant addition to that well I I I
I don't for a moment suggest that the
the built form is going to go all the
way up to the settl boundary that's
that's your point about the soft Edge
isn't it but nevertheless there is going
to be development pulled East very much
further than development currently
tracks East in this part of the
settlement isn't there it's going to go
further east I would again I would
disagree that it's very much further but
that's perhaps the point between us that
that's that's that's the sort of point
of judgment that I think we can safely
leave to the inspector to the extent
that it's pulled East every every new
house every degree of extension
eastwards weakens the linear form of the
settlement
um I'm not entirely sure that that's
true um in terms of how you experience
the settlement um well we come one
doesn't typ sorry no no go one doesn't
typically
experience on in an everyday on an
everyday basis um the the linear for
well sorry one doesn't typically
experience an aerial view view of a
settlement um when when considering the
identity one typically in an everyday
scenario would experience that as they
drive through walk through livein
experience a settlement um and my own
opinion is as you approach the changes
that would acre with the appeal
proposals in place would ACR for a short
well the change would be to a short
length of burnam Road short length of
steeple
Road in terms of the experience of the
settlement as you then go past the
appeal site on Burnham Road you're into
the the existing settlement um and you
don't then
experience the the appe we wouldn't then
experience the appeal appeal proposals
um strongly in a visual sense um you'd
be more focused on the immediate
surroundings to that road um which are
the which is obviously the existing
settlement um
context uh now you you you you've gone
to precisely where I was going to go
next anyway which is how it's
experienced on approach can can we begin
with can we begin with this Mr milc if
we're talking about the experience of a
linear
settlement any change in that experience
is almost always going to be perceived
as it's approached from the side isn't
it as you're traveling along the length
of the road which goes through the a
settlement almost by definition you're
not going to experience a change not
necessarily
if I take a a a different landscape
context for example if you were within a
valley and you were driving along a
Valley Road and settlement was extending
up the valley side you would experience
in a different way you would not only
experience those parts of the settlement
close to you but you'd experience those
potentially up the valley sides because
they'd be more visible of course in and
the flat landscape in this
instance to my mind mind um Narrows the
extent to which you would experience
these proposals as you traveling through
um the settlement the other way you
might experience this through green gaps
where you might see
um development beyond the green space or
along a road um but yeah I understand
your point that that the predominant
experience would be um of that
settlement as you try pass through it I
just don't think
it's I I don't think just because you
would typically experience from the road
means that it's inevitably you're not
going to experience the new parts that
are proposed no but in let's let's then
think about that in the context of the
denji Peninsula agricultural settlement
specifically can we I wasn't going to do
this but but I think we need to can we
just go back please to the
characterization assessment yes uh
3.20 I think hopefully everyone still
got it
open uh 6.1.4 please which was telling
us about the The Village core about
the the key linear
part do you have it I do and we'll note
five lines down it's talking about so it
start from three lines down part of 19th
Century Village relatively compact most
houses close to the road even fronted
directly onto the back edge of the
highway spaces between buildings were
minimal although are attached in tight
groups or rows so the nature of the sort
of Village cause we're talking about in
the denji Peninsula is such that green
Gap isn't going to be much for
consideration is
it uh I think that's that's talking
predominantly about the historic fabric
of the settlements rather than if if you
want to call the the nucleated additions
since the uh original um sort of birth
of the village if you like quite quite
so but we're we're talking here aren't
we about the ability to perceive uh
precisely the ability to perceive those
nucleated additions beyond the linear
core and it's a characteristic of the
linear core that it lacks green
gaps uh I set out here yes the the the
linear core yes the heart of the village
if we want to call that at lington uh
near the roundabout of the church yes I
would agree that the um that's an
accurate description yes that's an
accurate description and and not
withstanding that accurate description
of a lack of green gaps policy 61 as
we've seen still seeks to maintain
linear form right
uh yes fact it does seek to maintain
linear form
um but i' go back to what I said I think
it's it's um it's the extent to which
you can experience it and experience the
change brought about by a development
rather than um simply looking at the
historic core
element now in your evidence in Chief
you referred to a couple of the
viewpoints and it's the the Viewpoint
from the Burnham roads to the east of
the settlement that I I want to ask you
about I my my point is is largely at the
conceptual level so we don't necessarily
need it open but it's view point yeah
view point two view point two you know
the one I mean I do y so looking
northwestward up towards yeah now it's
in the nature of a Viewpoint isn't it
that it's a a snapshot in space it is
indeed yes and it is in the nature of
experience that it's not a snapshotted
space it is the traveling along the road
that we're concerned with uh it's a
sequential experience sequential
experience Fair way of putting it yeah
now you you I think fairly accepted in
Chief that from V Viewpoint to the
development is going to appear closer to
the viewer because development has been
pulled eastwards along the Burnham Road
yes uh agreed yes it's a it's a matter
of fact it will be closer and that being
so it's also a matter of fact isn't it
that as one travels Westward along the
Burnham Road one is going to experience
arriving at built form out of the right
hand window as it were to the north
sooner than one does at the moment point
one and two quite a way before one gets
to the bend b as burnam Road turns
north
um you
will experience the the
the whether you I'm not actually sure
you'll experience the development sooner
it will be closer to you as you travel
westwards along that road but as I
mentioned in Chief
the as you as you travel as you if one
moves further east along Burnham road
towards the sort of east of the Deni
Peninsula um there are houses there are
farmsteads there are um HS by the road
and within the fields immediately to the
north of burnam Road um which severely
limit the ability to to view the current
settlement Edge um I haven't done a
precise test on how
soon or whether it's I don't think you
would experience it much sooner if I'm
entirely honest but it would be
certainly in the early stages of a
greater scale in the view than it is
currently because it's
closer thank you last couple of
questions for you Mr milc we're we're
almost there um
first of all settlement size you you'll
recall that some evidence was given by
Mr Coleman about the impact of the
increase in the number of dwellings
within the settlement as it were not not
in landscape or visual terms but in
terms of settlement identity and
character that's not a proof not not a
point you've considered in your proof is
it uh not specifically no the the
increase in numbers of dwellings I
haven't
no o sorry I would I don't know if we
want to go there but I would make
reference to the there's a very useful
diagram within the design access
statement showing the figure ground of
um the extent if you like of additional
built form to the east it's not a a big
point I want to make I think I think we
we've seen from the various illustrative
plans where the buil form is going to to
be at least in illustrative terms so in
that sense I think we we've got that
point to I I don't I don't as I say
don't suggest built forms got to go all
the way to the edge of the seven or
anything like that final issue I'd like
to address with you please is a point in
your proof of evidence
6.32 please paragraph
6.32 which we find on page
31 and it's it's uh bullet point
[Music]
six begins using reference to Historic
Maps
and here
you describe the evolution of the
settlement if I can put it that way and
then say albe the appeal proposals will
represent a larger scale proposal than
other additions of the village espcially
speaking the further extension of the
Town eastwards onto the appeal site I
find to be consistent with the historic
growth of the settlement and a natural
next stage for growth of the village and
you use that as grounding your
conclusion there'd be no impact on The
Village's identity
I just want to want to to put this to
you Mr mil Christ and do tell me if this
is one for Mr
Armstrong the concept of settlement
growth is not in any way a natural
phenomenon is it it is a plan-led
phenomenon in this country uh it is yes
it is and so when one is considering
what the next stage of development ought
to be one ought to be considering at
least as the starting point where the
development plan tells you development
ought to
go uh I I that is probably more of a
question for Mr Armstrong and absolutely
but I understand
that would you like me to just go into a
bit more detail about what I've written
or have you you no no I I'm simply this
the simple point is this however however
natural one may perceive an extension to
be the drive of the acceptability of an
extension to a settlement is not whether
it's a natural Next Step it's whether it
is in accordance with the development
plan andless material considerations
indicate otherwise
is my take in a sense what I've what
I've written is uh from the context of a
landscape professional who who is
looking at
the the character and context of
latchingdon how it has grown and
developed in in the past and how it
might grow and develop in the future
were it thought that additional growth
was required so it's more of a a
landscape character and identity Point
looking at the extent to
which the development might or might not
um harm those aspects that's clear thank
you uh Mr mil I have no further
questions thank you very much thank you
sir thank you Mr will Cox um I have no
particular questions to ask at this
point I I asked you some questions
earlier on um Mr kuk do you have any
re-examination just a couple of points
so if I uh if I
may um I'd like you
to pick
up
um the design and access statement CD
1.7 and could you find within it please
PDF page 9 of
46 what section is that please Mr uh so
section six
page nine of 46 on the
PDF
consultation no so it's the document
page
16 section six character
analysis okay do you have that I do and
so what we have here is this so this is
the application character analysis it's
setting out at 6.1 an analysis of the
existing built environment near the site
which is useful to provide inspiration
and to okay whatever and then at
6.2 it's talking about the urban form
and the village expansion do you see
that and it's saying halfway through so
it's it's making reference to the
landscape character
assessments um that they're within the
planned landscape known as denji
form uh this form is characterized by
co-axial rectilinear field patterns
roads have developed at the boundaries
of the Rector linear Fields creating a
network of right angled roads and
Junctions around which linear
settlements have formed seems to be some
agreement between what set out here and
what Mr Coleman was telling us yesterday
and it then says while the origins of
latchington Village followed the Burnham
Road and the street later additions to
the village in the 1960s and more
recently have developed in depth Behind
These main through roads as Illustrated
at figure8 eight and you then can see
and we can
follow uh figure eight below and at 66
it's saying the main stages of
significant Village growth where new
streets have been introduced occurred
around the 1960s and
1980s and whils these newer editions do
not follow historic field boundaries
they continue a rect to linear pattern
within the Wilder uh wider field pattern
maintaining the general linearity of
latchingdon the 1960s and 80s dwelling
types are atypical of dwelling types
built across the country they take uh uh
little character reference from the
historical essic
vernacular okay so pausing there because
you were asked some question I'll come
to
the the the precise question of
clarification in a moment but what is
the apery the the the APO the apotheosis
that the classic form of linear
development the class as I understand it
I'm not a complete expert but I would
say it's single-sided along along roads
um hence the term ribbon development is
also used ribbon okay and if I look at
the dark red the areas up to
1895 how if at all would the settlement
pattern comply with that apery of
linearity it's It's precisely what you
would expect single sided with um
historic buildings on the Junctions of
the
roads next please you were taken to CD
320 so CD 320 which is the
characterization study and paragraph
6.1.5
is this an analysis of latchingdon per
se uh no this is this is an analysis of
uh the agricultural Villages as they're
set out in this document but it says
from the early 1900s groups of council
houses were often added to the fringes
of The Villages and these with Villas
Bungalows and then the
later M friend Mr goatley would
pronounce this cool
desac uh uh but
cacs uh of both local Authority and
speculative housing uh constitute the
equivalent of suburbs so how consistent
is that generic
proposition with the precise analysis we
have of lington what's the level of
consistency it's almost um exactly the
same really you have an ex a historic
linear um form from the 1800s um which
has then been added to as I explained in
in my evidence in in a number of
different areas um over the last 100 or
so years right so if we're trying to
understand as a starting point what is
the identity of latchingdon what if any
consistency or inconsistency is there
between this generic assessment and the
specific assessment we have in the
Des uh it's it's very similar okay so
then the next point then is uh
6.3 and what we have is what is called a
specific
policy do you see that I do now um is
this characterization assessment
referred to as an Evidence document
supporting policy
S1 uh no it is not it's not listed as a
key document is it a document to which
we should have reference in interpret
and applying policy
S1 is it referred to not specifically
but it's not referred to right what I
mean this might you might want to defer
this to to Mr Armstrong but respectfully
it's fairly simple what weight should we
attach to this as a
policy um given its part of an Evidence
base it's not related to that specific
policy um and it's of some age now uh
limited weight I would I would argue
right but it's more of a planning
and and what it's saying is as a matter
of
policy that closes and CER sex should be
avoided is there any national or local
policy or national or local design
guidance which supports the proposition
that closes and cuer SE should be
avoided not that I'm aware of no right
so I want to understand this then if we
were to follow this
policy and we were to have linear forms
of
settlements how would latchington
expand uh unfortunately in the same way
that many other settlements would have
to expand and that would be as ribbon
development along roads um right because
of the if there's no other way of
providing numbers of housing then that's
our only option so it supports the logic
is we have linear development going out
either side along Burnham
Road how consistent is that with
national policies requirement for
walkable
neighborhoods um not at all or or the
effective use of land well that was the
next point the effective use of land
right um where if anywhere can you point
to some national design guidance or
lands scape guidance which supports the
proposition that settlement should
expand in this ribbonlike linearity
form um simply there is none it's it's
not um really a viable in terms of not
using cars um or a from an Urban Design
perspective it's it's it's really un um
unconscionable really and my friend was
asking you about
scale and and you're saying well you
experience the scale as you're moving
along the roads if you were to expand
settlements so that its ribbon
development along burnam Road for
example would that have a greater or
lesser impact on one's experience of the
scale of latchingdon than what is
proposed which is compliance with the
rectal linear field
patterns well evidently it would have it
would have the effect of making
any linear settlement appear larger than
it was you're extending your experience
of the settlement um over a much greater
degree than you would for example if you
were to put 160 houses along the roads
in single-sided or Ribbon development
form it would it would make lendon
appear significantly
larger thank you sir those are my
questions thank you very much uh Mr kuk
um I have no further questions um so
thank you very much thank you
um I think it might be an appropriate
time to have a break um now it's it's
quarter past
12 um and we can then hear the evidence
of um in one piece in in one piece in
the afternoon um how how long did just
to recap you you said about 45 minutes
yes so I'm I'm going to address J record
you you you had a couple of points about
um about the application Ju Just just to
inform this and perhaps if you get a
second to look at it over lunch
statement of common ground at at
3.8 and and core document
1.27
um I I think that addresses the point
that you've raised and so so M friend
knows oh right oh well that's well then
as always so he's he's one step ahead of
me but if you were to just have a look
then you then you'll understand Mr
Armstrong's answers okay thank you very
much um good all right um well we'll
we'll take an hour today for lunch um
what what would be helpful as well is if
I could be supplied during the break
with if it's possible with um paper
copies of the um conditions and the
obligation if that if if that's possible
thank you very much so we'll resume then
at um quarter past 1 thank you thank you
very
much